[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sam
si nous en temps et un fils de pub
le fils de pub le seul commencer on y va
un peu mollo chacun présente sa chaîne
en une phrase ou deux allez c'est un peu
compliqué mais en gros c'est une chaîne
qui parle des images l est et d images
si possible étrange ou horrifique en
essayant de voir d'où elles viennent ce
qu elle influencé ce qu'elle cache comme
symbolique du coup ma chaîne développer
ce dimanche ça parle de développement de
jeux indépendants c'est une série de
journaux de bord dans lesquels je
raconte comment on fait pour développer
un jeu vidéo en partant de rien du tout
et peut-être un jour je l'espère allant
jusqu'à la sortie
oui moi ça s'appelle le mox est une
chaîne sur la littérature et la
littérature classique surtout de voilà
on essaie d'en parler de montrer la
place qu'elle joue dans nos vies et
quand je dis nous je parle de nous tous
vous êtes de on est de tout à fait il ya
mon collègue avec qui n'avait pas grand
chose à dire sur le sujet mais toute
façon c'est moi qui écrit des textes
donc c'est pas grave et moi donc c'est
maxime de la chaîne le fils de pub ou
dans chaque épisode en fait je critique
et j'analyse une publicité ou un concept
marketing
merci et pour ma part je suis valentine
de la chaîne sciences de comptoir où je
parle de cailloux pour commencer mais
dans la suite donc pour continuer je
propose que chacun choisisse un terme
qui qualifie sa chaîne et internes qui
ne la qualifie pas waouh comme ça sans
prépa la chaîne qui pourrait qualifier
on va dire fascination et la fin j'ai eu
pas pour moi j'aime mesures si je
travaille sur la fascination et le truc
qui me définirai pas c'est ennuis parce
que c'est vraiment le mon moteur common
anti moteur principal
moi je dirai ce qu'il qualifie c'est le
partage parce que le foot c'est vraiment
le partage de connaissances et ce qu'ils
qualifiaient pas ses jeux en dieu pas du
tout en plus j'aime pas les indiennes
nous je dirais que c'est l'expérience
esthétique ça fait de moi je suis désolé
c'est plus trois mots mais bon ça y est
voilà de dire que la littérature n a
touché un vendeur spéciale est un mot
qui qualifie pas ce serait la culture
moi c'est à dire qu'on est en bas les
couilles de faire la culture des gens et
de dire moi j'ai de la culture et jalu
plein de livres était dans sa cellule
une position qu'on va contre laquelle on
cherche à lutter à leur part et je vais
dire deux mots je m'excuse pour
qualifier l'esprit critique
ce que je dis la fin de chaque vidéo
donc je me dis que ça colle et par
contre ce qui me qualifie pas papier
peint ça c'est encore de mot c'est cool
ça colle tu triches beaucoup c'est cool
ça colle c'est bien si je
merci à relever du coup après c'est ce
petit exercice je propose que chacun
fasse en slam sur votre hyper bien alors
qu'est ce donc un programme formaté vous
attendez qu'ils respectent un format web
merci fabriquons remercier tous ces
beaux du jeudi
si je pense pas que ce soit ça qu'on
entende pas reprogramme formaté je pense
qu'à une connotation péjorative un
certain type de fonds même plus dans
l'idée de ces pas seulement qu'il
respecte je pense que c'est qui ceux qui
critiquent en forme de lyre est évident
et de la répétition de ce qu'on voit
déjà est quelqu'un qui dit eh ben moi
j'ai envie de faire une chaîne de gaming
dit je pense que ton programme a le
risque d'être formaté et peut-être que
même dans l'idée de formater il ya
l'idée de formules comme s'il y avait
une façon de faire qui ferait qu'avec ce
format là ça va marcher
la recette magique toi samatan je suis
entièrement d'accord avec tout ce que
vous n'étiez pas du coup oui c'est assez
rigolo ce que vous racontez puisque est
ce qu'on peut vraiment opposé programme
formaté et sujets de niche entendu comme
sujet qui s'adresse à un public
spécialisé j'imagine est ce que pour
vous il ya une opposition entre les deux
ne pas je te dire un truc
en gros on peut faire un sujet de niche
au rsa dépend formaté si on est ce qu'on
le décor l2 ce sa notion péjoratif dire
formaté sa s'opposaient niche à ce
moment là un truc que personne n'attend
qu'à une forme bizarre et c'est un peu
l'anti formatage lentilles formule mais
en même temps tu peux partir dans à fond
dans une niche et dire je vais faire un
truc hyper formatés dedans de dire
justement je vais venir investir avec
des trucs solide des trucs qui vont
parler aux gens et pourtant tu parles
comme un intrus mais gagné donc ça
dépend de ta de ton intention mais tu
peux avoir programmes de niches très
formaté en fait si ces excuses moi j'ai
un exemple pour sa part exemple c'est
tout ce qu'on qualifie de
des boucs tube je sais pas si c'est
quelque chose que vous regardez un peu
de nous comme on est dans la littérature
naturellement c'est des choses qu'on
observe on a été beaucoup d'ailleurs
relié à ça au début vous êtes une chaîne
youtube et tout ça en nous envoyant ce
que ce que c'était que les boutures ont
passé notre temps à dire non parce que
l'e-book tube c'est essentiellement des
personnes qui se filme avec extrêmement
peu de moyens enfin scam qui parle
pendant cinq minutes d'un livre avec
voilà un commentaire qui est autant de 2
comment dire de l'affect quoi si je puis
dire que du commentaire de l'intrigué
quoi simplement et il ya un milliard de
chaîne c'est à dire que c'est une
dimension youtube qui est extrêmement
horizontale c'est à dire que en fait les
gens peuvent avoir jean sérien 200
abonnés pourtant continué de faire des
vidéos pomme depuis cinq ans quoi et se
répondent les uns aux autres dit moi je
fais le challenge de jolies et pendant
24 heures parce que j'ai vu sur la
chaîne le machin et et voilà donc c'est
des trucs de niche parce que pas grand
monde regarde mais c'est extrêmement
formaté et est ce qui fait que du coup
quand on arrive dedans on a un peu
l'impression de se dire ce que fait un
tel je vais déjà vu chez un autre et
d'ailleurs pire encore pour les tags
c'était où les challenge et tout ça
c'est que du coup vraiment la langue
elle-même et la réalisation est la même
et la conclusion est la même
et quand il parle d'un livre ils ont
souvent aussi la même donc non pour
répondre à ta question
les pâtes distinction enfin y'a pas de
deux parce que je trouve que ce que je
voie intéressante tous les liens tout
que je vais juste dire que pour moi mais
en même temps tu viens de me faire
changer d'avis et que tu viens de dire
un petit peu mais je repose la réflexion
pour moi dans le côté formaté il ya un
côté répétition au grand nombre en fait
qu'on va retrouver beaucoup ou partout
mais effectivement je pense qu il peut
aussi y avoir du coût des formats de
niche formaté parce qu'il suffit qu'un
des deux ou trois qui répètent tous les
mêmes codes pourront effectivement un
format de niche formaté mais je vais
tendance à vous poser la question je me
pose non juste pour reprendre la
définition de la problématique chose que
ce qu'ils comme intéressant c'est c'est
un peu cette notion de risque de dire
est ce que je veux être là pour quelque
part marché assez vite assez fort à dire
ben le meilleur - de faire ça c'est un
peu d'aller vers ce qui marche tout dire
je vais reprendre tout ce que j'ai vu de
bons
ces formats l'afr mon format ou est ce
que tu dis je prends le risque de faire
un truc qui potentiellement peuvent
intéresser 10 personnes au départ est
peut-être d'avoir une traversée entre
guillemets du désert de deux ans jusqu'à
ce que peut-être tu abandonnes mais
parce que tu t'es dit ok y'a que moi que
ça intéresse les bordels c'est ça que je
veux faire quoi et rca sous tend un peu
l'idée je mets des guillemets un peu pas
de malhonnêteté mais un peu de 2 à
l'eesi je vais pas embrouiller c'est de
faire un truc un peu créatif je vais
dire ça ça marche le fait enfin il ya un
petit peu ça qui est péjoratif et a fait
partie de la péjorative it et du terme
de dire tu t'es pas foulé d'après un
truc existe déjà quelque part c'est ce
que disait un créatif dans un thread sur
twitter ya pas longtemps il parlait des
carottes et il disait que quand on veut
créer un nouveau contenu il faut un truc
qui soit un peu original et en même
temps qui perturbe pas complètement les
gens par exemple s'ils vont au rayon
carottes et qui trouvent des carottes un
peu mieux que ce qu'ils prennent
l'habitude ils pourront les acheter
parce que ils connaissent déjà les
carottes mais s'il trouve un espèce de
légume car non pas possible et qu'elle
topinambours par exemple eh ben ils vont
peut-être pas allé naturellement vers ce
produit là donc il faut une certaine
familiarité avec la forme en tout cas
pour pas trop déboussolés les gens et la
question je me posais sur tous et vous
parlez de forme à vous parler en même
temps de sujet on parle de fin on parle
de fond finalement est-ce que le
formatage ça concerne la forme ou le
fond est ce que le fait d'avoir un sujet
de niche c'est plus pour les sujets
abordés en plus la façon peut-être parce
qu est-ce qu on peut dire que
l'astronomie est un sujet de niche par
exemple pour moi l'ultra formatage c'est
quand tu as vraiment les deux quoi quand
vraiment sur la forme et le fond tu vas
retrouver un million de vidéos pareil
après je pense que c'est comme tout a
sûrement un peu de nuance dans le tas
moi par exemple je traite un sujet qui
est plutôt de niche le développement de
jeux indépendants il y en a pas des
masses mais je m'inspire quand même de
codes liés à youtube sur le montage par
exemple sur l'utilisation de même ou de
musique qui est quand même assez à
formater donc je pense qu'il ya des
chiennes qui tombe ni vraiment dans
ligne vraiment dans l'autre je sais pas
trop comment
c'est facile de les positionner là
dessus qu'on justement est-ce que vous
même vous définiriez comme un sujet de
niche comme le chêne de niche des uns
des autres
moi non je certainement pas je pense que
la littérature
il n'y a pas moins de niche je dirais
d'abord à fortiori en france en tant que
pays je crois que l'on est celui qui a
le plus grand pour atteindre de
librairie tout le monde considère non en
permanence on aurait pu se dire quand on
commençait que notre public
majoritairement féminin parce
qu'effectivement c'est essentiellement
une majorité de femmes qui lise gagnon
voilà plus de femmes qui disent que de
me tillie source sources la vie
l'observation et le des choses
empiraient non je suis désolé c'est vrai
que c'est des choses qui sont que je ne
suis pas mais qui me semble assez
éloigné de la réalité mais en fait il ya
énormément de gens qui sont dans les
domaines scientifiques etc et qui
viennent nous voir et qu'ils nous disent
pas super bien parce que moi même j'ai
eu toujours été un peu gêné m'éloigner
la littérature est de faire que des
maths et de faire des 0 et des 1 comme
toi mais en fait justement votre chanel
me permet d etc donc même des gens qui
sont parties complètement l'opposé
continue de dire ben y'a quand même un
peu en poids symbolique au fait de
parler de la littérature
alors que moi je m'en fous des maths je
vais je absolument je dors sur mes deux
oreilles ne pas savoir faire du calcul
mental quoi ce qui est gênant quand on
va à l'épicerie par exemple donc ce que
je veux dire c'est que je pense que la
littérature au fond du fond c'est pas du
tout un sujet de niche parce que ça la
littérature que qui est apprécié et qui
est apprécié par le plus grand nombre
c'est justement celle qui arrive un peu
à saisir le fond de l'âme la complexité
des épingles quoi est donc finalement
quand on lit j'en sais rien la recherche
du temps perdu je pense que l'essentiel
de la raison pour laquelle on se
rappelle de la recherche dans perdu
c'est parce que chacun dans l'intimité
de son propre boudoir pas si vous avez
un boudoir pour lire le sperme
et ben se dit merde [ __ ] je sers
marseille il a vachement il est
vachement bien compris des trucs quoi il
me comprend moi et je pourrais mettre à
sa place et il lui arrive à se mettre à
ma place
donc non la littérature c'est un sujet
de niche après c'est pas parce qu'on
n'en voit pas à la télévision que c'est
un sujet de niche c'est à dire qu'il ya
quand même un peu une façon que les
grandes productions d'une image qu'ils
ont installé une image stéréotypée
mais leur image stéréotypée parle de
gens qui n'existent pas c'est à dire que
les gens qui disent moi j'adore hanouna
et et j'ai jamais lu un seul livre de ma
vie je pense que ça n'existe pas je
pense que voilà même des gens qui aiment
beaucoup se divertir quand ils
rentreront chez eux sur le des gens qui
les gens qui regardaient le mic qui
misent pas de lit visiblement les gens
ont l'air de dire que ça pourrait
exister mais est ce que est ce que
voulaient parce que c'est une image les
autres que vous avez aussi une image
autre que vous avez elle peut être
fausse si c'est vous encore chaud peut
en discuter
vous voyez ce que je parle du oui alors
moi je considère en revanche ce que je
fais comme de la niche parce que même si
le jeu vidéo en soit c'est plus vraiment
de la niche et aujourd'hui enfin c'est
quand même un divertissement très
répandue ça rapporte plein de sous on
aime bien dire que ça rapporte plein de
sous tout ça c'est très mainstream
en revanche le développement en lui même
déjà je trouve que c'est en soi de la
niche et le parcours personnel de
développement dans une création
artistique dans le jeu vidéo enfin en
fait ya pas mal de gens qui m'ont déjà
posé la question s'il y avait d'autres
gens qui faisait ce que je fais sur
youtube en tout cas dans youtube
francophone j'ai trouvé personne
donc je pense que je suis de l'ultra
niche parce que j'ai l'impression que
personne fait ce que je fais en tout cas
dans la sphère francophone
donc ça l'est mais après il ya aussi pas
mal de choses qui sont associés à la
niche en tout cas dans l'inconscient
collectif c'est le côté peu accessibles
souvent se dire des trucs de niche doit
être un peu des trucs pointu et l'eau
intello voilà alors que par exemple sur
ma chaîne c'est de la niche mais il ya
une réelle volonté d'être accessible
même aux gens qui n'y connaissent rien
du tout donc c'est de la niche
accessible en tout cas moi ce que je
fais et pédagogique
je me posais la question ce que
justement se pose la question de savoir
si de niche ça veut dire qu'on est peu à
traiter justement ce n'est pas ce que tu
disais par rapport à la littérature ce
que finalement c'est une thématique qui
effectivement très large et qui parle à
beaucoup de monde
est ce que c'est le fait qu'il y en ait
peu sur le youtube francophone français
qui enfin je suis ni je ne sais pas et
je me posais la question pour ma chaîne
parce que je crois à 20,2 ce que je sais
on et 3,4 à paraître de publicité ou en
tout cas être dédié à ça sur youtube
mais le fait est que le marketing la
publicité il y en a partout le temps de
vous en permanence donc sujets de niche
sur youtube oui après effectivement
thématiques qui ne l'est pas forcément
comme pour la littérature j'imagine moi
je pense que enfin c'est super
intéressant si vous vous dites et je me
demande s'il n'y a pas une niche toi moi
mais les échos c'est ya pas eu de niche
plus en fait dans le traitement quelque
part parce que effectivement tu peux
avoir un sujet qui est pas du tout
traités alors que des millions de gens
en consomment tous les jours donc est ce
que c'est de fait ce pas une niche des
millions de gens les mais c'est une
niche parce que tu es le seul en parler
pourquoi il ya si çà et là sur un même
sujet on va tous parler de sport il y en
a un ou une qui va paraître d'une façon
en vue et d'une façon qui va parler un
peu de monde mais qui va parler beaucoup
à un petit nombre de gens je pense que
ça c'est dans la niche est alors mal
pour revenir à ma chaîne j'ai trouvé un
jeu de mots qui était cool s'est déniché
il ya deux côtés
non mais c'est en train de se faire
devant vous là je vous l'offre il ya moi
sens que je peux y avoir une idée de
dénicher c'est à dire de dire tiens je
vais chercher ce truc qui est
apparemment un peu obscur hook est connu
que par des gens qui ont creusé sept
thématiques etc et d'essayer de dans le
traitement que j'en fait de l'ouvrir à
un maximum de gens de se dit souvent
d'essayer de parler autant si je traite
de belote bornes autant parler à la
personne qui a fait 2 5 fois et qui
connaît tous que la maman quoi et je
pense qu'on peut réunir les deux et que
peut-être c'est la façon dont tu traite
quelque chose finalement que ce soit n'y
joue pas dans la réalité des chiffres
c'est une autre question presque en fait
c'est plutôt est ce que toi dans la
façon dont tu abordes ce sujet a
l'impression de le faire d'une façon
ni je veux dire aussi original en fait
dans l'idée de dire tiens c'est pas dire
seulement originale parce que là en fait
excuse moi ces travaux l'autre enfin ça
veut dire original c'est vrai mais ça me
fait penser à autre chose c'est que
parce qu'on a défini formaté mais niche
je pense
il me semble que ça vient de
l'expression la niche écologique
c'est-à-dire le moment où les dinosaures
il ya 65 millions d'années je sais que
je crois dinosaures ont été détruits et
ben là ni géologique s'étaient tous les
animaux qui ont résisté aux radiations
et des trucs comme ça et l'hiver le
mulhouse oui et qui du coup était dans
un petit dans un petit truc est en fait
on réussit du coup à pouvoir un peu
aller partout et donc ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'il est possible que dans
ce sens là il ya quelque chose de
bénéfique à être dans un une niche c'est
à dire de 2,2 peu de peu d'autres
personnes qui traitent le même sujet
parce que du coup le la facilité du
formatage on est moins gros on parlait
tout à l'heure de tous les gens qui
imitent chiodi paille mais en même temps
ça se comprend pas ce que je veux dire
ce qui fait etc il a effectivement
souvent des idées originales et tout le
monde les imitent
parce qu'on voit bien le résultat que ça
mais comme je pense que dans donc c'est
ce qu'on a dit dans chacun de nos thèmes
il n'y a pas vraiment d'autres personnes
qui soient à renommée internationale et
qu'ils fassent la même chose
et bien c'est hyper libérateur parce que
du coup c'est vrai que vous vous
retrouvez à vous dire bon alors comment
est ce que je vais parler d'un livre en
vidéo parce que quand même complètement
con je n'y avais pas filmer une page où
j'ai pas ou qu'est ce qu'elle est mais
du coup est ce que vous faites juste un
commentaire mais du coup ça n'a pas
d'intérêt parce que l'épousé comme envie
que les gens ne lisent le livre est pas
juste qui vous écoute parler du livre
m'est donc est ce que vous lisez est-ce
que vous changez rien bref et donc les
questions à se poser sont un peu un no
man's land un horizon du possible et on
a des trucs quand même passé que la mémé
mais voilà et donc je pense que
ça invite pour chacun à se dire comment
est ce que mon sujet il peut avoir un
traitement visuel intéressant parce que
c'est ça youtube c'est quand même que
quand on dit oui mais face came to sah
bon avec une cabine bibliothèque
derrière etc
c'est vrai que c'est un peu nul même si
pourtant ça ressort d'une illusion
puissante qui est de dire que hyper
visuels de dire je parle en regardant
l'objectif même si le spectateur le sait
très bien et ben en fait quand on
regarde la vidéo on a vraiment
l'impression juste ça marche
parfaitement que le type s'adresse à
vous donc il ya quand même une habilité
visuel un traitement voilà une
spécificité du traitement visuel donc
comment traiter du du développement du
las des films d'horreur et de et du
synthétiseur et du marketing
spécialement en vidéo c'est là où je
pense que il ya vraiment quelque chose à
faire et qui est et il est bénéfique
conçoit de niche pour pas imiter
simplement ce que quelqu'un d'autre
devrait tomber juste petite précision sa
niche écologique et panne et géologie
des pierres
deux ex je suis à colog en plus on est
en fait la niche écologique c'est
l'ensemble des paramètres physiques d'un
milieu qui d'enfin qui sont exploités en
quelque sorte donné donc genre tu as eu
une espèce qui herbivore elle aura pas
la même niche une espèces carnivores et
tout et on s'en fout complètement
oui donc genre de jeu qui a été détruite
et la leur nous y voilà enfin de la
niche existe toujours la niche c'est un
objet abstrait c'est juste le fait
qu'elle soit vacante
ou alors occupé donc justement un sujet
de niche on va occuper une niche qui
n'est pas prise
l'idée d'avoir pris un peu quelque chose
qui était papa sow né citer un peu le
trésor que tu as trouvé dire oui si un
chien dans la niche cas pas en mettre un
deuxième but exactement
sauf si grand tu peux tu peux en mettre
2 et du coutach répétition entre les
chiens qui meurent diffère t il quelque
chose
et du coup oui je me pose une question à
ce sujet ni jeu forcément ça va
peut-être pas touché absolument tout le
monde et pourtant vous avez un public
qui est assez conséquent je me demande
est ce que ça vous a fait peur de vous
lancer sur youtube sur un sujet quand
même relativement de niche surtout si
vous vous êtes dit je tête vouloir en
vivres ou comment vous avez appréhendé
ça eh ben moi à la base j'ai pas
vraiment eu plus peur que ça sur le fait
que je traitaient d'un sujet pas très
répandu puisque je le faisais en me
disant pas aux pierres enfin je m'en
foutais un peu faim je le faisais pour
moi et pour ma famille sache que si j'ai
quitté mon travail c'est pour travailler
sur un autre truc en matin c'était
vraiment juste et aussi pour moi c'était
de garder une trace de demont
développement garder des archives voir
le chemin parcouru et à la base c'est
vrai que c'était une démarche très
personnelle et en fait je réfléchissais
pas trop au fait de plérin public
puisque je voulais vraiment faire un
truc qui déjà me serait utile à moi et
me plairait à moi et c'est peut-être un
peu ça le truc de la niche et finalement
tu penses pas
une cible je pense pas marketing tu
offres un truc
et si les gens en veulent eh ben c'est
super ils vont ils vont venir ils vont
encourager vous regardé et je pense que
c'est peut-être ça la base en fait des
chaînes un peu de niche c'est vraiment
mettre en avant un truc qui toi te
passionne avec tout en angles
d'observation avec ton style personnel
et c'est ça qui fait que ça sera
relativement unique puisque même si on
est pas tous un être élu un peu spéciale
on a quand même jour spécificité quand
même propres je pense que c'est ça tu
prends un risque énorme parce que du
coup tu as une part de hasard énorme de
jamais dû par d'autres gens aiment les
je m'en fou tellement fait en tout cas à
titre personnel au musée si je suis pas
vu limites tant mieux comme ça personne
en retard chine après j'ai quand même
l'intimé conviction qui est parti au
moment où effectivement on part avec
cette logique là de parler de quelque
chose qui nous passionne et pas
forcément de chercher à plaire à tout
prix en répétant des codes juste un peu
vide et ben l'intéresse c'est que
justement on va parler de quelque chose
qui est intime pour nous mais qui la
plupart du temps touche le plus grand
nombre et oui c'est là qu'on en fait on
découvre qu'il ya des gens qui peut
aussi s'intéresser à ce même sujet de
niche et alors moi juste pour répondre à
la première partie des questions un peu
comme la quand j'ai fait ma première
vidéo
je pensais pas du tout et youtuber je
les fais à 35 piges un peu par désespoir
pour faire au moins un truc dans ma life
dont je sois fier quoi et et après c'est
venu après et même le nom de la biennale
de 136 on ne peut faire plus anti sexe
que sa face avant du rêve d'un fusible
enfin c'est triste ou quoi et en fait
bizarrement moi je comprends pas faim je
comprends pas j'ai avec les plus de
pincettes
je vois pas l'intérêt de faire un truc
qu'ils soient pas ta niche en fait et
dans le sens où moi si j'ai voulu parler
de ça c'est parce que je voyais pas des
gens qui m'aurait satisfait dans ce
canal où je redirai pas c'est bon il a
tout dit ou elle a tout dit c'est génial
a besoin de faire un truc là dessus je
me sentais solitaire dans
mon expérience je voulais la partager
surtout que ça faisait 15 ans que jamais
comme un bordel
moi je trouve ça passionnant ça sort ça
pourrait intéresser des gens mais
clairement je n'ai pas fait je pense que
si tu commences une chaîne youtube en te
disant ça va marcher et déjà dans le
format en fait avant même de t'en rendre
compte c'est que tu sais qu'il ya des
recettes un objectif tuer dans une
démarche beaucoup plus entreprenariale
en fait quelque part même si c'est pas
un mauvais mot mais je veux dire qu'un
objectif
tu sais que machin il a marché comme ça
ça ça va pas marcher joe papp
voilà tu vas partir de tout cas pas
marché mais moi j'ai pris un peu le
contre-pied inverse on sens je mets pas
ma tête en miniature le nom n'est pas
sexy je mets mais maintenant j'ai même
pas de pub de mom & vidéo donc
techniquement je peux même pas mon temps
en tendance il ya un peu cette idée de
anti marketing qui va un peu avec le
format de dire un format savait qu'une
façon de le ramener de le vent de
partager et bizarrement savais que les
gens qui arrivent je pense sur ma chaîne
alors ça a mis beaucoup plus d'heures ça
a marché je suis ultra euros et c'est
incroyable parce que justement chossat
méga niche et que on est de plus en plus
à occuper cette niche et tout mais pour
autant je pense que la plupart des gens
qui viennent c'est par du bouche à
oreille d'un nicheurs qui il parle à un
autre michel tanguay mien ça mais je
pense que beaucoup de gens sont arrivés
par le biais de niche si l'on repérait
le petit truc et c'est un truc qui se
partage plutôt que le cinéma de machin
ou et où la vue qu'on a attiré par un
thème quelque chose un peu plus formaté
quoi et du coup c'est bizarre mais ça a
marché
aussi je pense qu'à ce que je je romps
né dans l'anti format en fait donc votre
public est un hipster en fait non
on est tous les lecteurs de quelques
heures déjà ça n'a aucun sens et
aytus avant ma chemise où nous
accueillons monsieur sam bienvenus
désolé c'est la faute des rebelles tvi
qui voulait me interviewé est ce que est
ce que tu veux commencer par représenter
vis tu fais ta chaine rapidement un mot
un terme
oui toujours tu veux tu peux souffler
excusez moi à tanger pas fini les
conseillers un terme qui qualifie la
chaîne est un terme qui ne la qualifie
pas et la définition de niche fait trois
volées d'escaliers et c'est un terreau
surprise génial c'est quoi la première à
oui je suis bon des jeux j'ai une chaîne
de pensée critique de d'épistémologie de
philo des siens sain tous ces trucs là
j'analyse les faits que news y analysent
les croyances analyse les sujets
souffler je parle avec des personnes qui
sont considérées comme des ennemis entre
guillemets du de la rationalité je leur
donne la parole
j'essaie de les écouter
et tout ça dans la joie et la bonne
humeur avec beaucoup d'humour belge et
après avec quoi un mot qui qualifie la
chaîne est un mot qui n'a qu'à l'équipe
mot qui qualifie machine est à tout ce
qui brille comme toi ta gueule comme ça
balance un mot qui qualifie ma chaîne
comment talent un mot qui qualifie la
chaîne le talent et les autres
industries en manque il n'y a qu'à les
finales annoncé la chaîne j'ai envie de
dire j'ai juste envie de dire on va dire
et éthiques
vannes oc s'est pas même si ces jeux
veut tout dire et rien dire est un mot
qui la qualifie la qualifie pas vous
êtes éthiques mais voilà mais voilà je
suis complètement bêta c'est génial
c'était dit merci à vous merci à lui et
sait tous que ça veut dire niche oui non
ça c'était le bonus était pas obligé
d'accepter bonus bleus on l'avait fait
ou pas je suis solidaire ceux qui
partent de niches écologiques niches
écologiques
après l'arrivée à l'heure mais c'est
l'histoire de combats de chiens tu
comprends
donc vous faites des oui non mais parce
que pardon mais sauf si tu voulais
sauter sur une autre question mais
j'avais quelque chose à répondre c'est
que le ça donne l'impression que le
public et leapster parce que
effectivement tu t'adresses à des gens
qui peuvent dire ouais moi je regarde
des vidéos qui font quatre mais je pense
que c'est pas l'objectif
en fait est que et qu' il n'y a pas
quelque chose de d'étranges au fait de
dire que que in fine est au rsa pourrait
potentiellement plaira pas à plein de
gens on en parlait tout à l'heure avec
elle de 136 mais jeudi son truc c'est
quand même le le fantastique le la peur
et cdc des émotions et des sentiments
qui sont qui sont ressenties par tout un
chacun je dire baudelaire aussi bon bah
son truc et hyper apprécié c'est pas
pour autant que ça le décrédibilise bien
au contraire même c'est plutôt positif
parce que ça veut dire que les voilà les
les
les émotions qu'il a réussi à distinguer
sont justement celles qui sont
ressenties par tout un chacun donc d'une
certaine manière le je pense que il y
aurait quelque chose de dommages aux
fêtes de ce2 ce2 ce sont deux voilà son
or et du caractère un peu de niche de ce
qu'on fait de dire bah oui moi j'ai pas
comme tout le monde et ses méthodes
en fait et tout ce que ça marche et
qu'il est plein de gens qui aiment ça
qui découvre un peu parce que ça ça en
dirait long je pense sur le fait par
exemple max et carlito je veux dire il
ya quand même tout le temps quelque
chose d'étonnant à à des aléas des à bab
à des succès comme ça tu vois c'est à
dire que ça donne envie de se dire mais
quelles sont les choses que e.on ont
compris the pardon et et que d'autres
qui font des podcasts sur les profs
n'ont pas comprises et c'est une signe
c'est une question ouverte
c'est pas de dire que si philippe et
l'hyper bien mais c'est de dire que je
pense que leur leur forme a dit quelque
chose de 2,2
voilà de la complicité d'un sens du
collectif
il ya une vidéo d'alfie qui en parle de
justement le petit truc de mcfly karito
mais qui est très intéressante je vous
encourage à aller voir ça tu peux
spoiler et ils disent que lui et en fait
on va en parler rapidement dans sa vidéo
alfie il en parle bien mais point par le
grosso modo du côté moments vrais
moments de vie en fait pas vraiment de
vie de joie qu'on partage avec eux parce
que du coup ils ont toujours cette bonne
humeur est toujours ce côté ultra trop
gros pour 800 passagers rigole quand je
vote non le prout une promiscuité en
fait c'est un team eux c'est le côté
authentique
je pense que le côté authentique ou abba
qui compte aussi beaucoup sur youtube
j'écoutais webedia aussi bien la marche
pas ils le font bien je trouve je me dit
pas à quelle bande d'hypocrites je crois
que mc fly quartetto sont vraiment comme
ça dans la vie que tu adores je me goure
mais ils ont vraiment pas j'ai pas
l'impression de voir des gens qui se
foutent de moi mais j'ai bien conscience
que c'est une énorme machine avec des
budgets pub incroyable et ils peuvent
appeler toutes les stars qui veulent
voir le youtube heures de base où es tu
bosses tu passes n'a pas cette force de
frappe malgré tout tu vois mais je pense
qu'ils prennent vraiment plaisir à faire
leurs vidéos et du coup on le ressent à
travers un gîte à fait on part du
postulat que vous voulez avoir plein de
public et être riche et c est ce que
c'est un but pour vous de toucher
beaucoup de gens oui c'est cool tu sais
pas ce que c'est
il y aurait même un caractère d'utilité
publique puisqu'elle a fait très mal
très honnêtement à la base quand j'ai
quand j'ai découvert ma chaîne youtube
c'était absolument pas pour toucher
plein de gens s'étaient pas ce que je
voulais diffuser les making of de mon
fils et pour l'équipe
et puis pour ceux que ça intéresserait
points puis c'est devenue une chaîne de
pensée critique par hasard et là c'est
devenu un but de toucher un large public
effectivement ça s'y prête
je trouve ça un peu dommage de réduire
youtube à une course aux abonnés
effectivement tous et c'est pas du tout
c'est un lieu où on pose des trucs qu'on
a envie de partager le point d'un réseau
social
juste je voulais moi en tout cas je sais
que j'ai envie de toucher plein de monde
mais c'est pas pour la cette phrase dans
son contexte
touchez pas non on en reparlera plus
d'abonnés mais en fait c'était pas le
but non plus à la base mais aujourd'hui
si j'ai envie que mon travail se diffuse
tout simplement parce que ben mon
objectif c'est de rendre accessible le
la création en fait de jeu vidéo qui est
perçu comme quelque chose de très
élitiste il faut dans l'esprit collectif
l'inconscient collectif faut vraiment
être un petit génie de l'informatique il
faut avoir tous les toutes les
compétences de la terre alors
qu'aujourd'hui on vit à une époque où ça
n'a jamais été aussi facile de faire un
jeu tu sais pas coder c'est pas grave tu
sais pas faire du graphisme c'est pas
grave
dix mille outils pour tdc accessible
c'est gratuit et en fait ya tellement de
gens que je croise qui me disent qu'ils
ont envie de faire ça et qu'ils se
mettent des barrières parce qu'il pense
que ça va être quelque chose que ça
n'est pas je me dis si ma chaîne peut
aider à faire en sorte que plein de
petits créateurs et créatrices puisse
enfin passé le pas parce que finalement
ils se rendent compte que c'est pas si
difficile
moi au final c'est plus devenu sale but
parce que en vrai il faut être réaliste
aussi devenir riches et célèbres et que
sa chaîne youtube
à moins d'avoir vraiment mais des
millions d'abonnés c'est irréalisable et
ya pas assez de place pour tout le monde
en tout cas pour ça je pense sur youtube
donc vaut mieux pas que ce soit
l'objectif sinon il ya de très fortes
chances d'être déçu quoi on en parlait
ce matin d'ailleurs dans la conférence
vivre de ses vidéos sur youtube le biais
du survivant on voit jamais que ceux qui
réussissent sur youtube mais on voit pas
tous ceux qui ont échoué il ya un
article dans numerama qui est sorti a
pas longtemps qu'ils en parlent
justement de ces petits vidéaste qui
n'ont jamais percé et ça c'est
intéressant de voir tous les tous les
facteurs qu'on peut pas forcément
prédire une question j'ai juste
la question d'un par rapport au fond et
à la forme je pense que même si vous
souhaitez tous deux sujets de niche
il ya quand même je suppose un point
commun entre vous tous qui fait que nous
avons pu faire c'est justement sur dans
un milieu aussi compliquée que youtube
c'est une certaine forme de charisme et
là je parle pas d'eux je parle pas de
beauté physique ou quoi mais il ya
quelque chose je pense qui est commun à
tous les youtube heures qui ont un
certain succès mais c'est ça le problème
c'est que effectivement il ya un
charisme mais comment tu te définis mais
oui et ça c'est hyper hyper ont brillé
mais je sape et là je vais parler de
petite personne que je planais qui ont
essayé les famines petite chaîne youtube
et je pense que c'était pas toujours une
question de contenu un pense que consul
était parfois extrêmement intéressant
mais qui avait peut-être pas assez de
moyens
bon sens bonne caméra etc et aussi il ya
il faut juste avoir incarné ce que tu
fais pas de prestance de d'offrir une
image qui plaît un minimum
je pense quand même par image il ya
aussi un mot beaucoup moins beau mais
quelle image de marque en fait dans le
sens et quelques est moche mais si on
l'appliquait de l'humain ça peut être
assez bossé de dire 'est-ce que tu
arrives à habiter ce que tu fais à
témoigner de la passion ou à le mettre
dans un écrin qui fait que tiens ça
c'est juste c'est pas que intéressant il
ya aussi ce petit truc assez
indéfinissable qui fait que ça va
attirer les gens ça va leur parler ou ça
permet de de faire vivre quelque chose
habiter un sujet de niche en fait c'est
peut-être ça aussi la clé de réussir à
l'extraire de cette liste c'est que à un
moment tu arrives à trouver le levier
qui fait que ça parle à beaucoup plus de
gens
cojean de la niche initiale qui était de
dans des attentats après on peut pas
dire que des youtube heures
charismatique qui ont un contenu de
qualité où il ya tout pour réussir et
qui décolle pas faut pas dire que ça
n'existe pas il y en a plein c'est le
facteur chance aussi dont on n'a pas
parlé aux gens ce terrible quand la
chance est il une énorme
[Musique]
là il ya la chance et puis à l'entr'aide
aussi je sais pas si vous avez la chance
c'est l'entraidé la chance et quand
quelqu'un qui cite des td en fait c'est
l'agencé naître dans une communauté
si tu vois ouais alors par exemple le
café des sciences c'est une association
de vie des associatifs iq et on sent
très tous vachement se connaissent tous
pas mal
et vous êtes vous même l'entité en fait
c'est vous même café des sciences donc
les gens qui s'intéressent au café des
sciences s'intéresse à tous les joueurs
qui sont dans les temps disons que
quelqu'un d'autre vienne me chercher je
pars un forum avec 10 millions de
personnes qui veut dire à lui c'est
génial de partager les 10 millions le
suivre je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
rare que un vidéaste qui a une grosse
audience qui te dis allez voir ce que
fait cette personne c'est génial enfin
moins clairement sans patrick bauchau
encore à mille abonnés j'aurais arrêté
mais clairement fait donc la chance elle
est là en fait elle est la chance qu'ils
aient regardé mon tweet avant les 6200
autres qu'ils étaient proposés en fait
et ça ça fait un peu flipper parce que
clairement on envoie moi ça me fait mal
au coeur de voir les dizaines et les
dizaines de gens qui font un terme de
malades et/ou sapers pas quoi sa
personne à percer ça veut rien dire mais
où ils ont pas l'audience qui mérite
quelques pas et alain verte voit des
gens qui font des millions de vues ou
c'est de la merde et ben ouais ben c'est
comme ça
y en a trop maintenant je vais pas dire
non parce que c'est la main pour moi
mais ça peut être génial pour d'autres
gens et de façon tout aussi concrète
mais c'est juste que voilà tu peux vite
ressentir le dire il n'y a pas de
justice sur youtube c'est sanaa ça
n'existe pas j'ai beaucoup de chance et
du travail parce que tu es exposés et tu
fais un truc où on sent que t'as pas
bosser ça va pas marcher non plus au
fond quoi matin il n'y a pas de
méritocratie sur youtube non mais tiens
d'ailleurs ça me donne une idée si vous
pouviez chacun site est une chaîne qui
vous plaît une chaîne de niche qui
mériterait plus d'abonnés d'après vous
là comme ça au débotté mais pas la nôtre
on veut dire les bon je vous laisse
réfléchir du coup moi j'ai déjà cité
alfie je vais réfléchir à une autre
succès déconcertant moi j'en avais cité
ulmet mais j'ai appris qu'il a fait une
collab avec dirty belhadji donc j'ai pas
trop je pas trop lui faciliter les
choses non plus quoi
non mais je déconne mais il ya
évidemment la chaîne de medi1 mehdi
moussaïd foule aux copies qui est qui
est extraordinaire là on parle de
charisme bas ça se pose là quand même
mais chercheur en sciences des foules
ouais chercheur en sciences des foules
alors ça a l'air comme ça un peu mais
c'est extrêmement intéressant c'est
génial et qu'on le comportement d'une
foule en tant qu'objet c'est génial il
vient de sortir un bouquin d'ailleurs
acheter l'eau ce n'est pas un placement
de produit et moi je conseillerais elle
est en train de commencer à monter c'est
s'appelle au de what the fake elle fait
de l'esprit critique mais ce que j'aime
particulièrement c'est qu'elle le fait
par l'angle journalistique c'est à dire
que les journalistes et que moi j'adore
les journalistes et qu'on vit une époque
on déteste les journalistes et que c'est
une énorme connerie détester les gens et
c'est bien mal comprends leur travail et
je trouve qu'en plus de faire de
l'esprit critique et d'aller chercher
des réponses de dira à ce que je prends
l'exemple asselineau a dit ça va je vais
l'appeler en fait personne ne fait ça en
fait on est toutes adhérentes aux
arguments il va montrer qu'elles n'ont
aussi parce que je trouve génial c'est
quelque part elle montre la tambouille
du journaliste on va dire de façon babel
et où tu te rends compte qu'en fait
c'est un vrai travail d'aller chercher
l'info d'aller en allemagne pour
rencontrer la personne qui a bossé là
dessus au lieu de prendre la ligne de
forums que tout le monde croit bêtement
et je trouve qu'elle arrive à faire des
critiques tout en disant elle
journalisme c'est pas si mal en fait
c'est pas un truc salle si tu le fais
avec une donc j'espère qu'elle va avoir
plus de vue parce que je pense qu'elle
fait aussi du bien à sa façon au métier
de journaliste par le biais de youtube
bizarrement fait moi je recommanderais
dans catégorie jeux vidéo la chaîne de
osmosis qui font un travail mais de ouf
de recherche ou en gros il parle de jeu
coop mais ils font pas que de la
critique review de jeu coop c'est à dire
qu'ils vont se plonger dans l'histoire
des développeurs à l'origine de ces jeux
sur leur vie comment ils ont évolué dans
quel milieu social quels ont été les
déclencheurs qui ont fait que le jeu
vidéo est arrivé chez eux quelles sont
vraiment les
les aspects de leur personnalité qui
ressort dans leur jeu et aussi parle pas
mal de la portée politique de certains
jeux vidéo et c'est un sujet super tocci
dans la communauté gamers thème la
politique dans le jeu vidéo ça plus
jamais et ils font ça vraiment super
bien et ça demande des heures et des
heures de recherches et de boulot et
ça m'embête de voir qu'ils décollent pas
plus donc abonnez-vous à oslo this c'est
bien ils sont gentils dany toi oui moi
je dirais la chaîne de boccia geek
parce que je trouve que c'est des gens
qui font un super travail de 2,2
exactement comme je le disais de mesla
de da proche un peu de ce que c'est que
la politique qui se manifeste à travers
la pop culture je trouve ça chouette
parce que d'abord c'est hyper important
je pense de se rendre compte que rien
n'arrive dans un dans un vacuum culturel
quoique en fait le lieu il ya toujours
des rapports de force qui se manifeste
quand au disney fait un film c'est
effectivement une certaine histoire
qu'ils ont envie de raconter et je le
trouve qu'ils font de deux d'un côté qui
extrêmement comment dire honorifique
pour le spectateur c'est à dire qu'on se
dit il faut un travail qui est d'une
approche assez humbles et qui pourtant
et c'est d'aller au fond du sujet qu'il
prend jamais de vous et moi je me perds
sensible à la façon dont la personne
s'exprime c'est à dire que si vraiment
même si le contenu est intéressant si le
type a un peu l'air de me prendre pour
un compte si je ne supporte pas
probablement un manque d'estimé de moi
même mais ça c'est pour mon psy mais
voilà alors que vraiment ils sont là ils
voyaient qu'on réfléchisse ensemble avec
toi et moi je trouve ça chouette
merci moi je voulais juste une petite
chose ça peut paraître un peu bizarre
mais tu parlais de savoir est ce que
votre but c'est d'avoir le plus
d'abonnés ou pas alors ça peut paraître
bizarre dit comme ça mais je le pense
vraiment dans ce sens moi mon but
c'était de pouvoir en vivre parce que
j'avais 36 ans j'étais grave dans la
merde je voulais ça faisait 15 ans que
je voulais me battre là dedans est tout
et puis un jour ça arrive etc
mais maintenant que
enfin c'est horrible sur typique existe
c'est génial il ya des gens qui me
soutiennent et qui font que bah du coup
j'ai un petit peu plus d'un smic c'est
est ce que j'ai gagné a vendu coup bas
j'ai pu arrêter mon taf et faire ça et
limite j'en ris d'hermann en bas je suis
hyper heureux s'il ya des gens qui
étaient pour la chaîne ça mais j'ai
aucunement envie de dire il faut que je
monte à 200 milles et puis à 500 mis les
pieds au mur
je peins tant mieux si ça arrive mais
clairement c'est surtout un objectif et
j'ai même envie d'aller plus loin je
serait vachement bad trip 2 que des gens
dont la communauté dans un autre délire
un peu moins bienveillants et c'est
partage d'agendas allez voir ça et que
tu trouveras etc sang d'une personne qui
sont plus forcément dans la connaissance
de là où tu viens de ta petite niche
qu'il faut prendre un peu avec des
gentiment avec des pincettes et cardozo
mais comment tu peux dire sa fin ça
arrive très vite dès que des communes
qui d'un coup arrive et qui te
ressemblent pas et en fait je préfère
moi j'ai vachement de gens ça va bien
marcher tous les jeux ça restera comme
ça toute la vie que je serais super
heureux parce que quelque part ben je
peux vivre de ça me consacrer à fond et
que j'ai des gens qui meurent envoie
plein d'énergie de bienveillance et j'en
veux dire l'univers qui allez maintenant
fogel millions c'est quoi ton but on
s'en fout tu vis de ça ça marche de
revin je comprends pas cette idée de
croissance à part si comme tu dis il ya
une vraie dimension de dire de lier de
l'utilité publique de dire il faut plus
de gens soient au compte ce message
parce que ça va changer nos vies que
c'est important et c'est d'où la
politique là je peux comprendre qu'on a
envie de toucher les deux variantes si
ça arrivait j'arrêterai de demander des
dons typique tu vois pas ce que je veux
pas spécialement
ouais c'est cette course de fous tu vois
si la pub te permettait de ville sur la
rue pour étudier pas je suis aussi dans
cette optique ou voilà moi tout ce que
je veux c'est cette peinard et faire mon
truc quoi qu on foute la paix je veux
pas être le nouveau si près un nouveau
machin kamel mouassa manga serait
terriblement jeu pour les avoir vus un
peu je pense que c'est des gens aussi
qui sont réalisés par la pression énorme
de 10 millions de personnes qui vont
voir mon truc quoi effectivement tous
les tous les gros gros youtuber que j'ai
croisé pas très enviable
leur vie en forêt c'est assez anxiogène
en fait beaucoup et certains même ont
arrêté ou sont un peu enfreint vis-à-vis
de loi du côté acea terrorisante te dire
bon bah je suis un petit youtuber et
d'un coup je fais plus de vue que la
grosse émission de prime time enfin
c'est très bizarre quand leur relation à
leur travail est gâchée aussi il ya une
pression il ya des pieds de plomb
souvent qui s'installe enfin c'est
d'imaginer ce que les gens attendent de
toi plutôt que de faire ce que tu veux
vraiment faim ça peut être très vite
donc oui puis non je sais pas si en tant
que nicht a juste envie d'arriver au
mans où ça y est bon j'ai ma petite
place au monde est content le tout mais
de dire allez on va emmener la niche
dans fins a pas tellement de sens en
fait tu peux pas emmener la niche en
fait il a dû s'y étaient rivés dans une
dalle de béton mais je pense qu'on est
tous dans ce cas là c'est juste on a
envie de pouvoir en vivre tout en
gardant notre liberté de création parce
qu'effectivement moi j'aurais peur de la
responsabilité parce que c'est aussi un
sujet difficile en ce moment c'est la
responsabilité des créateurs et
influenceurs vis-à-vis de leur
communauté
effectivement si tu diffuse un message
très orienté très politisée a énormément
de gens bas après faut aussi se dire est
ce que je dis bien pas de conneries est
ce que je vais pas engendrer des
mouvements de foule de harcèlement des
trucs craignos et pour moi ça c'est une
responsabilité que j'ai pas envie
d'avoir non plus donc rester petit chêne
finalement c'est aussi vers des petits
harcèlement peinard et j'envoie ma
communion fut c'est bon vous arrive à 12
il permet
mais pas content mais même si le en
vivres pose aussi une autre question
justement du risque de retomber dans le
formater à un moment donné parce que si
on doit en vivre eh bien il faut être
régulier
il faut que ça continue à plaire etc etc
donc est-ce que c'est pas aussi un
risque de devoir faire abandonner des
compromis pour en vivre c'est exactement
à ce que j'avais demandé mais du coup
c'est ça c'est que ça nous amène à une
nouvelle distinction conséquences qui
peuvent jouer c'est la différence entre
un quelque chose de formater
c'est-à-dire de effectivement d'un peu
engoncé où tu te répètes par rapport à
toi même et le format tout simplement et
le fait de dire que tu peux tout à fait
avoir une émission et pendant pendant un
an tu la tiens et même peut-être plus
parce que finalement si jamais tu arrive
un peu à distinguer le les éléments qui
permettent au spectateur de se dire ok
j'arrive sur cette chaîne je reconnais
cette émission il ya déjà un peu la
promesse du truc comme mcdonald's veut
dire tu tu t'y vas aussi plus facilement
parce que tu sais ce que ce qui a aidé
parfois elle le goût de la surprise
il est anti 295 oui c'est ça mais disons
que il ya quand même ce truc qu'on
arrive sur la page youtube et là d'un
coup tu as 500 propositions tu dis mais
merde je sais même pas sur quoi j'ai
envie de cliquer et donc là tu tentes
sur quelque chose je te dis ah oui voilà
une promesse un peu de j'ai déjà vu des
épisodes de cette émission là qui me
plaît et ben alors j'y retourne je pense
que c'est important d'être attentif
aussi mais on le sait facilement nous
mêmes parce qu on est certes
vignasse mais on est aussi spectateurs
d'autres chaînes et donc là voilà il ya
une dimension un peu psychologique je
trouve qu'il est important de ne pas
négliger dans le fait de dire que voilà
le formatage c'est quelque chose de
néfaste mais qui se distingue du fait d'
adopter un format et jeudi comme un
comme si tu étais ya pas de vidéo sans
forme a d'ailleurs même un truc alerte a
décidé que ça commencerait par sac c'est
une forme de formage te rejoins formaté
et formate deux choses bien différentes
ça fait mais est-ce que à faire toujours
le même format le public risque pas de
se lasser
je vous demande aussi à vous est ce que
si vous voyez j'ai pas 6 millions
d'émissions de c'est pas sorcier vous
voulez seriez pas au bout d'un moment
6 millions peut-être ça dépend du
contenu de la nation oui la forme sert
le font au final parce que par exemple
j'ai pas des trucs hyper hyper populaire
alors 13 ans je sais même pas combien de
ces horizons mais je veux dire ça a
fonctionné quand même hyper italiens ou
les simpson 22 saisons doit quand même
toujours la même époque où le maine
forme avant ça peut-être un petit peu
diminué ou quoi mais ça continue
[Musique]
alors la question je vous pose c'est
pourquoi certains vidéaste enfin
peut-être beaucoup je sais pas essaye de
trouver régulièrement des nouveaux
formats essaye de se renouveler pourquoi
à votre avis franchement moi je suis
vraiment très très fort dans ce cas là
c'est à dire que je sais très très bien
ce que mon public veut voir et jeu et
c'est plus fort que moi si j'ai une
envie une pulsion d'un nouveau format
je m'en fous je me lance et et je suis
en baisse de vue et tout est mais je
m'en fous parce que je le kiffe et plus
important si tu veux et je pense c'est
une hygiène de vie de garder ce qui
fausse entre de la chaîne tant que ça
met pas en péril toute la chaîne
évidemment mais mais jusqu'ici j'ai
sacrifié d un bon 0 2 dans mes vues en
général pour continuer à faire des
renouveler dans ce qui me faisaient qui
fait quoi
j'ai une idée je me lance point koala de
le risque c'était plus la lassitude du
créateur au final c'est que tu veux dire
ouais c'est ça c'est ça qui est très
important et c'est ça qu'on observe
d'ailleurs chez beaucoup de créateurs je
vais pas citer de noms mais il y en a
beaucoup qui quittent et primes mêmes
qui font leurs vidéos de dire eh les
gars là je me retrouve plus là dedans
j'ai envie de faire autre chose et il y
en a eu plusieurs chez des gros
producteurs qui fait très fort mais
coûtera 4 ans et où tu sens que sont un
peu prisonnier du truc et sont valeureux
quoi mais ça pour moi c'est propre à
toute la création en général en fait moi
j'ai la même chose dans le jeu vidéo ça
fait bientôt trois ans que je bosse sur
le même j'ai qu'une envie c'est de faire
autre chose dans le jeu vidéo on a aussi
je sais la série smash bros par exemple
qui fonctionne super bien les fans
adorent mais sakurai le gars à l'origine
du toit qui en a marre qu'on lui parle
de smash bros tout le temps il veut
faire autre chose et même si ça marche
super bien je pense que quand tu as un
peu créatif et que thèmes proposés
et des choses tu peux tu vas t'ennuyer
était obligé de prendre des libertés
comme tu dis quitte à sacrifier quelques
vues moi c'est pareil j'ai lancé
d'autres formats qui marche moins bien
que mon format habituel mais je suis
quand même très contente de le faire
parce que moi en tant que créatrice ça
m'aide aussi à rester motivés et aussi
tu as touché d'autres personnes dans ta
propre niche c'est à dire que mois
suivant mais format je sais qu'il ya des
gens qui vont préférer celui ci doses
qui vont préférer celui là et finalement
c'est cool parce que tu te crées encore
des niches dans ta niche une sorte de
niche cepsum
c'est dû rater un métier j'ai tenté mais
voilà mais oui je pense que quand et
créatif été obligé de changer sinon
comme tu dis c'est la déprime assurés
quoi monsieur qui a aussi une idée de
trouver ma maquette c'est de trouver le
format qui pourrait faire que je
m'ennuie jamais c'est à dire que tu me
juger plusieurs formats y en a même un
qui est lourde et pour je voulais
prendre le nom d'un ancien format pour
faire un truc et verenahof c'est une
connerie parce que je pense que ça vaut
mieux marcher pour ça mais j'avais envie
de le faire je voulais ce nom là donc
voilà les deux buts c'est trouver un
format où tu dis purée ce truc là je le
ferai bien le 15 en quoi et c'est dur
c'est à dire de dire j'ai trouvé un truc
que je me retrouve là dedans j'ai pas
l'impression grand monde le fait même si
c'est que toujours qu'une illusion mais
tu t'en fous et de dire je crée en fait
une matrice c'est ça l'idée du format en
fait créé une matrice qui laisse dedans
départ infinie de renouvellement en fait
et c'est l'autre les termes mais du coup
et je pense qu'effectivement vous là
vous avez raison c'est que je pense que
le spectateur au delà même du contenu au
delà même de la personnalité ou de
l'aura du créateur ce qui veut voir
c'est quelqu'un qui s'éclate quoi et ça
paraît bizarre mais je pense que il ya
plein de gens quand le le vidéaste et
met en doute la réponse est toujours un
monde du manga ou meuf fais ce qu'il te
plaît non de suivre à pour ça et je
pense qu'elle est vraie viewer qu'il
faut bichonner sais ce qu'ils te disent
éclate toi en fait et c'est là la clé du
truc si tu t'éclates plus tu te
retrouves prises et d'un format ou pire
à nourrir une espèce de bête qui te
ressemble plus kita devient même
toxiques on voit des gens qui s'enferre
dans un format parce que leur public est
composé la majeure partie de gens qui
sont barrés dans ce truc là et quand
même tu voudrais faire autre chose va tu
prends le risque d'achêne du jour au
lendemain ça s'arrête quoi et quand tu
vis de ça et que
t'as pas envie de retourner faire le taf
que tu fais avant qui ne plaisait pas à
quoi c'est un piège un peu de ses treks
la fête qui vous fait ce qu'il fait
c'est un bon mot de la fin et même je
dirais que c'est le seul conseil qu'il
faut donner à quelqu'un qui veut se
lancer et qui va diriger en rien par et
kenny et touba est ce que tu aimes
vraiment ça et c'est quoi le truc qui
fait que parce que c'est tellement dire
on n'en a pas trop parlé mais ok là où
on est là on est hyper heureux on vient
mais il ya des journées d'août ya des
trucs ou août et ta famille te dis mais
ça n'a pas marché ton truc on a tous
galéré de ouf avant d'arriver au moins
on dit ça y est c'est trop bien la niche
mais en vrai on a juste tous eu
l'inconscience de continuer et ce qui je
pense nous a fait venir c'est qu'on n'a
eu pu identifier très tôt que tant pis
c'est une niche mais bordel je me
battrai pour ça hyper longtemps et c'est
ça qui fait qu'au final peut-être ça a
marché c'est que les gens ont ressenti
une forme pas de passion qui fait que
pour moi c'est le truc que tu dois
jamais sacrifié dans ta tête tu peux
changer tous les formats ce que tu veux
mais ne touche jamais à ça parce que tu
vas te perdre et les gens ont senti rsa
offrait bien merci beaucoup merci
c'était trop cool merci beaucoup merci à
toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]